[Music]
we're all just shook to the core with
this
five people for that we know very well
are
no longer with us they were very
prepared very safe
and they should this shouldn't happen
family and friends are grieving tonight
after a crash kills
five local cyclists and injuries several
more
thank you so much for joining us at 11
i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez that group was on
a route that a lot of people
are very familiar with and police still
really aren't sure exactly
why it happened that crash shut down
though part of u.s 95
south of boulder city for hours earlier
today and we do have team coverage
tonight orco mana shares
the impact this incident is having on
the local cycling community
but we start with sasha loftis she's
live near the end resort
where today's ride began sasha
brian i spoke with some tonight who were
members of the local cyclist community
and who knew those who died today
they say they can't believe today's ride
that was supposed to be a celebration
turned out like this
they said their hearts are with those
who lost their lives
as they begin to deal with this horrific
tragedy
is a heartbreaking it's an agony
many can't imagine but luigi gurian
knows too well
as he copes with the loss of his closest
friends now you got to go places where
you hang out with these people
and they're not there anymore his
regular cycling group was involved in
this horrific crash
thursday five were killed and three
others were hurt
along the u.s 95 near boulder city after
a box truck drifted into their lane
and hit them we're all just shook to the
core with this
five people for that we know very well
are no longer with us
paul manguel who also knew the group of
at least 15
echoed luigi's devastation we knew once
we found people had passed away
we knew it would be somebody that we
knew paul said the tragedy has shocked
everyone
but he hopes it sheds light on the
dangers cyclists face
across southern nevada i'm just really
saddened by all this and
the more i think about it i really just
hope that people
will pay more attention when they're out
there on the road and though their
riding partners are gone
both will do their best to honor their
memories
every time they head out on the road i
know right now those people want us to
be riding
now paul and luigi just want to remind
everyone to of course be careful watch
out for them on the road
and to remind everyone of the nevada
state law that states that you have to
give a bicyclist
three feet at least or move over a lane
when you're in your car
passing them along the road for now
reporting live sasha loftis
8 news now